(man) TONIGHT,
HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE NEXT BIG BUSINESS IDEA
WILL ENTER THE SHARK TANK
SEEKING THE FINANCIAL BACKING
TO MAKE THEIR DREAMS
COME TRUE.
YOU WERE ON THEM LIKE A BUZZARD
ON A GUT WAGON.
(laughs)
THAT'S ROBERT.
YOU'VE JUST DESCRIBED HIM.
I LIKE YOUR STYLE, BABY.
THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA.
HOW MUCH DID YOU PUT IN?
A COUPLE MILLION.
WOW.
(Barbara) OH.
I'M OUT.
(Robert) HOW MUCH IS LEFT, BOB?
THERE ISN'T.
(Daymond) I'M OUT AGAIN.
(laughs)
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
$800,000,
AND IT JUST VAPORIZED?
IF YOU WORKED FOR ME,
I'D FIRE YOU RIGHT NOW.
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
DAYMOND, YOU ARE
ONE GREEDY SHARK.
YOU'RE A VAMPIRE.
(laughs)
YOU'RE SUCKING THE LIFE
OUT OF GEORGE.
YOU'RE GETTING EXCITED.
(laughs)
WOW.
♪♪♪
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS JAN AUGENSTEIN,
AND I'M FROM
YELLOW SPRINGS, OHIO.
FOR MY DAY JOB, I WORK IN
REAL ESTATE AND I REHAB HOMES.
IN THESE TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES,
PEOPLE STILL WANT TO REDECORATE
AND MAKE THEIR SPACES BEAUTIFUL,
BUT WE JUST DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO DO IT.
BUT I HAVE FOUND A WAY
THAT YOU CAN GO AHEAD
AND CREATE THAT BEAUTIFUL SPACE
ON A VERY LIMITED BUDGET.
FAMILY IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IN THE WORLD TO ME,
AND ACTUALLY, MY BROTHER
SUPPORTED ME IN THIS VENTURE.
I TURNED TO HIM FOR MONEY,
AND HE PARTNERED WITH ME
IN THIS IN THE BEGINNING.
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS,
MY BROTHER HAS INVESTED
SO MUCH MONEY IN THE PRODUCT.
WE'VE HAD SOME SETBACKS.
I'M SO SORRY
IT DIDN'T GO BETTER.
OH, NO, IT'S FINE.
I MEAN, IT'S‐‐IT'S A RISK.
I TOOK IT. WE TOOK IT.
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT, JUST...
IT'D BE NICE
IF WE HAD SOME HELP.
I LOSE SLEEP AT NIGHT THINKING
HOW MUCH MONEY I OWE MY BROTHER.
I KNOW THAT MY BROTHER
BELIEVES IN ME,
BUT I WOULD BE
TOTALLY HEARTBROKEN
IF... IF‐‐IF I COULDN'T DO IT.
(voice breaking) IF THE SHARKS
DON'T INVEST IN MY COMPANY,
MY BROTHER WILL BE OUT $250,000,
I MAY BE OUT OF MY HOUSE.
I JUST DON'T KNOW.
♪♪♪
HELLO.
MY NAME IS JAN AUGENSTEIN,
AND I'M FROM
YELLOW SPRINGS, OHIO.
MY PRODUCT IS FridgeFronts,
AND I'M ASKING FOR $100,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR
30% OF MY COMPANY.
I WAS LIVING IN BASE HOUSING
IN 1999,
AND WE HAD
A HIDEOUS REFRIGERATOR.
YOU REALLY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE NOT
IN LOVE WITH IN YOUR HOME.
JAN, UM, JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY,
WHAT'S BASE HOUSING?
OH, MILITARY BASE HOUSING.
I WAS AN AIR FORCE WIFE,
AND I LIVED ON A MILITARY BASE.
AND THEY PROVIDE HOUSING
FOR YOU.
AND BAD FRIDGES.
YES. SO I CAME UP
WITH THE IDEA
BECAUSE WE HAD AN APPLIANCE
VERY SIMILAR TO THIS.
IN FACT, THIS PROBABLY
COULD'VE BEEN IT.
SO MY PRODUCT, FridgeFronts,
IS A MAGNETIC SKIN
THAT'S A DECORATIVE FINISH,
AND YOU CAN EASILY
CUT IT WITH SCISSORS
AND APPLY TO ANY APPLIANCE
JUST LIKE THAT.
IT'S VERY EASY TO DO.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
SO IN THIS ECONOMY, YOU MAY
HAVE A FRIDGE THAT WORKS,
BUT THAT'S JUST UNATTRACTIVE
AND UNAPPEALING.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND PURCHASE
THIS FOR UNDER $100,
AND CHANGE THE COMPLETE LOOK
OF YOUR APPLIANCE.
I ALSO HAVE OTHER DESIGNS.
MOST PEOPLE LIKE STAINLESS.
SO I HAVE STAINLESS FINISH.
I CAN DO DECORATIVE FINISHES.
ANYTHING‐‐JUST FUNKY.
WE CAN GET CRAZY.
THE‐‐THE‐‐THE POSSIBILITIES
ARE COMPLETELY ENDLESS.
JAN, DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
YES. I STARTED IN '05.
WE GOT OUR PATENT AT THAT TIME.
AND THE FIRST THING WE DID
WAS SkyMall.
SO I THINK WE DID
$40,000 IN SALES.
DID YOU HAVE TO PAY
FOR THAT SPACE IN SkyMall?
YES, I DID.
YEAH.
IT WAS ABOUT $18,000.
SO YOU‐‐ON $18,000,
YOU GENERATED $40,000 IN SALES.
MM‐HMM. YES.
WAS THAT ABOUT A BREAK EVEN
FOR YOU, GIVE OR TAKE,
OR DID YOU MAKE
A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY?
WELL, NO.
WHAT HAD HAPPENED IS,
WE WERE SORT OF AT THE MERCY
OF OUR PRINT HOUSE.
AND THEY HAD QUOTED
A PRICE FOR US,
AND WE SIGNED ALL THE PAPERWORK.
THEY CAME BACK
A COUPLE MONTHS LATER
BEFORE IT WENT INTO THE CATALOG,
AND CHARGED US
AN ADDITIONAL $10.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE THAT
IN THE CONTRACT
WITH THAT PARTICULAR SUPPLIER?
NO.
JAN, YOU'RE‐‐YOU'RE
AT THE MERCY OF ONE SUPPLIER?
WE WERE AT THE TIME, YEAH.
WE'RE FROM A SMALL TOWN IN OHIO,
WE WERE JUST GETTING STARTED.
WE HAD NOT
DONE TRADE SHOWS YET.
SINCE THAT TIME,
WE'VE DONE A FEW TRADE SHOWS
AND MADE SOME CONNECTIONS.
SO WE COULD DO THIS
BY HAVING IT DONE OVERSEAS
AT A CHEAPER COST.
BESIDES THAT ONE SkyMall TEST,
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER SALES?
YES. ACTUALLY, THE OTHER THING
THAT HAPPENED,
IN '08, RACHAEL RAY
FOUND US ONLINE.
THEY WANTED TO RECREATE
A KITCHEN JUST LIKE RACHAEL'S.
THEY USED OUR PRODUCT.
I MADE A CUSTOM ONE FOR THEM.
THEY PUT IT ON AIR. WE DIDN'T
KNOW HOW MUCH SERVER ACTIVITY
WE WOULD NEED TO SUPPORT IT.
SO WHAT HAPPENED WAS,
OUR SERVERS CRASHED...
OH, GOSH.
WE HAD SO MANY HITS.
AFTER YOU GOT HOW MANY ORDERS
DID IT CRASH?
WELL, THERE'S ANOTHER
LITTLE PROBLEM. (laughs)
OH.
I HATE TO‐‐I KNOW.
IT'S A LOT OF NEGATIVITY‐‐
OH, MY GOSH.
I KNOW.
(Robert) YEAH.
BUT WE KEEP GETTING UP
AND TRYING. IT'S LIKE A PHOENIX.
SO WHAT HAPPENED THAT TIME
IS THE, UM, PRINT COMPANY WE
WERE WORKING WITH WENT BANKRUPT.
OUR PRODUCT, WHICH WE'D ALREADY
PAID FOR, WAS STUCK
IN THEIR
BANKRUPTCY WAREHOUSE.
SO WE HAD TO BUY IT BACK, WHICH
HELD US UP, LIKE, TWO MONTHS.
AND BY THAT TIME,
PEOPLE LOST INTEREST.
JAN,
THERE'S NOTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT THAT MAGNETIC FILM,
IS THERE?
WE CAN DO‐‐
THIS IS AN ADHESIVE.
WE CAN DO A FOIL ADHESIVE
TO THE MAGNET.
BUT‐‐BUT WHAT IS THE PATENT?
IT'S A UTILITY PATENT
THAT WE DID GET.
SO YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE
WHO CAN PUT A STICKER
ON A FRIDGE?
MAGNETIC, YES.
DO YOU HAVE PRODUCT NOW?
YES.
YES, I HAVE 1,500 BLANK SHEETS
THAT ARE READY FOR PRINTING.
AND THEN I HAVE
ABOUT A THOUSAND
OF OUR OLD PRINTED DESIGNS
IN A WAREHOUSE.
DO I HAVE TO TELL YOU
WHAT MODEL FRIDGE I HAVE
OR I CAN CUT IT?
WE WENT TO
A ONE FILM LIKE THIS,
A SKIN
THAT YOU CAN CUT YOURSELF.
JAN, I'M CURIOUS. HOW MUCH MONEY
DO YOU HAVE IN‐‐IN THIS?
I'M GLAD YOU ASKED.
$250,000 SO FAR.
WHERE THE HECK
DID YOU GET $250,000
FOR A REFRIGERATOR MAGNET?
MY BROTHER.
HE REALLY BELIEVED IN MY IDEA,
SO HE SUPPORTED ME
AND HE INVESTED.
I FEEL OBLIGATED TO REPAY HIM.
AND HE STILL BELIEVES IN ME
AND THE PRODUCT, BUT HE JUST
COULD NOT CONTINUE TO PUMP
THE MONEY INTO THE MAGNETS.
AND SO HE KINDA
GOT BURNED OUT.
VERY PRAGMATIC, I MUST SAY,
BUT IT'S NOT A COMPANY.
IT‐‐IT'S ACTUALLY A PRODUCT.
I CAN SEE HOW‐‐HOW THIS WOULD
BE SOMETHING PEOPLE BUY,
BUT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
A COMPANY,
I'M OUT.
JAN, GREAT PRESENTATION. YOU
SEEM LIKE A VERY NICE PERSON.
FOR ME, IT'S TOO SMALL,
A VERY CUSTOM‐ORIENTED BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
I DON'T HAVE A CLEAR DIRECTION
ON WHERE I CAN
HELP TAKE THIS BUSINESS,
SO WITH THAT,
I'M GONNA RESPECTFULLY BE OUT.
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
JAN ONLY HAS TWO MORE CHANCES
TO MAKE A DEAL.
JAN, I HAVE A QUESTION.
♪♪♪
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA AND KEVIN HARRINGTON
ARE JAN'S LAST CHANCES
TO MAKE A DEAL.
JAN, I HAVE A QUESTION.
HOW MUCH INVENTORY
DO YOU NEED HERE?
THE MAJORITY HAS BEEN, LIKE,
FOR, OUR BEACH PRINT,
AND I WAS GONNA SHOW YOU THAT.
CAN‐‐MAY I?
YEAH.
AND THESE ARE JUST
FROM OUR EARLY DESIGNS.
(Robert) OH, LOOK AT THAT.
THAT'S A PRETTY LOOK.
YEAH, AND WHAT WE CAN DO‐‐
THE THING I'M MOST EXCITED
ABOUT, WE ONLY HAD FIVE DESIGNS,
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO WITH A PROPER
INPUT, IS TO HAVE A WEB SITE
WHERE YOU CAN SEND IN
YOUR OWN IMAGE.
WE CAN CUSTOMIZE IT‐‐
YOUR KIDS, YOUR FAMILY,
YOUR DOGS, YOUR CAT.
YOU COULD ALSO DO
YOUR DISHWASHER...
YEAH.
AND YOUR MICROWAVE
AND WHATEVER‐‐
I MEAN, OTHER THINGS
AROUND THE KITCHEN, RIGHT?
EVEN WASHER AND DRYERS,
MM‐HMM.
UM, I HAVE AN INTEREST IN THIS.
I THINK IT'S A CHEAP ASS WAY
TO DOLL UP A REFRIGERATOR
AS WELL AS OTHER APPLIANCES.
SO IF YOU'D BE WILLING
TO JUST LIMIT YOURSELF TO THREE
BEST‐SELLING DESIGNS...
THEN I WOULD GIVE YOU
HALF THE MONEY.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET
ANOTHER SHARK
TO GIVE YOU THE OTHER HALF.
♪♪♪
IF I GAVE YOU $100,000,
UM... WOULD‐‐WOULD YOU BE ABLE
TO GET ON TO A‐A QVC, HSN?
WELL, WITH THE $100,000, WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON SOME NEW DESIGNS
AND ENHANCING THE WEB SITE
TO DO THE CUSTOMS.
SEE, I‐I‐‐MY INTEREST WOULDN'T
BE FOCUSING ON NEW DESIGNS.
IT WOULD BE FOCUSING ON
SELLING WHAT YOU HAVE, OKAY?
ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN,
YOU'VE ALREADY SPENT $300,000
TO DEVELOP
A MYRIAD OF PRODUCT, OKAY?
TO GO DO SOMETHING NEW
IS‐‐IS TO ME RIDICULOUS.
WHEN YOU SAID YOU SPENT
$18,000 IN SkyMall
AND BROUGHT BACK $40,000,
THAT'S A BIG SUCCESS TO ME.
IF BARBARA AND I
EACH HAD 25%...
MM‐HMM.
I'D PUT MY $50,000 UP
TO HER $50,000.
I'D BE IN.
YOU'VE GOT AN OFFER.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
♪♪♪
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT SOUNDS
PERFECTLY FAIR,
BECAUSE I WOULD APPRECIATE
YOU GUYS TAKING A CHANCE,
AND YOU SHOULD GET HALF.
IS THAT A YES?
THAT'S A YES. I ACCEPT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, JAN.
(laughs) THANK YOU.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD LUCK TO BOTH OF US.
THANK YOU. I'M SO HAPPY.
THANK YOU.
GREAT.
YES!
THE SHARK TANK WAS MY LAST HOPE
FOR THE BUSINESS.
IF I HAD NOT HAD THIS DEAL,
THE COMPANY WAS JUST GONNA
FIZZLE OUT IN MY BASEMENT.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
THE SHARK TANK WORKS.
A SHORT TIME AGO WE MET
ENTREPRENEUR ALAN KAUFMAN,
AND WATCHED HIM STRIKE A DEAL
WITH KEVIN HARRINGTON
AND DAYMOND JOHN.
ALAN, I CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I'LL LIVE AND DIE WITH YOU GUYS.
YOU GOT A DEAL.
WE GOT IT. GOOD.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY, GOOD JOB.
THANKS, ALAN.
I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU.
♪♪♪
I'M ALAN KAUFMAN,
AND I'M THE CREATOR OF NUBRELLA.
NUBRELLA IS A NEW,
REVOLUTIONARY UMBRELLA DESIGN.
IT'S THE WORLD'S
FIRST HANDS‐FREE UMBRELLA
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY IMPOSSIBLE
TO INVERT.
THAT‐‐THAT WOULD BE IDEAL
BECAUSE...
(Daymond) SO TODAY
I'M BRINGING ALAN OVER
TO CLOSE A DEAL
WITH THE SHARPER IMAGE.
HELLO. WELCOME TO
SHARPER IMAGE.
AT THE PUSH OF A BUTTON,
THEY CAN PUT THE PRODUCT
IN EVERY HOUSEHOLD
AROUND THE WORLD.
SO THIS IS
A MULTIMILLION‐DOLLAR DEAL.
THAT IS TERRIFIC. I'VE NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THAT
IN THE MARKETPLACE.
FOR TWO YEARS, I TRIED TO GET
A DEAL WITH SHARPER IMAGE,
AND ONE CALL FROM DAYMOND,
AND HERE WE ARE.
ALAN,
YOU HAVE A GREAT PRODUCT.
GREAT. I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE RELATIONSHIP.
I CAN'T
THANK THIS GUY ENOUGH.
I AM SO EXCITED
TO BE WORKING WITH HIM.
THANKS, BUD.
♪♪♪
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS BOB KROUPA,
WHO NEEDS AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
TO SAVE HIS
ONCE‐SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS.
♪♪♪
HELLO, EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS BOB KROUPA.
I'M HERE TODAY
LOOKING FOR $500,000
FOR A 30% STAKE IN MY COMPANY
NEW ERA BRANDS‐‐
CLIP'n'GO MINT AND GUM
AND CLIP'n'GO CONTACT LENS CASE
PRODUCT LINES.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
FORGET THEIR BREATH FRESHENER.
BUT WITH MY CONVENIENT
CLIP‐ON CASE
THAT CLIPS ON
TO YOUR BACKPACK, KEYCHAIN
OR PURSE STRAP...
FILLED WITH MY...
(keys jangle)
POWERFUL,
SUGAR‐FREE MINT AND GUM,
YOU'LL NEVER FORGET
YOUR BREATH FRESHENER AGAIN.
THE MINT AND GUM BUSINESS
HAS ANNUAL SALES
IN THE BILLIONS,
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
BLOWING BUBBLES ANYMORE.
FUNCTIONAL PRODUCTS
WITH ENHANCEMENTS
IS GROWING
IN THE MULTI‐BILLIONS.
I WANT TO TAKE
MY EXISTING MINT AND GUM
IN A WHOLE NEW DIRECTION,
ADDING ENHANCEMENTS,
LIKE VITAMINS AND ANTIOXIDANTS.
I'M ALSO INTRODUCING
MY CLIP'n'GO
DUAL‐SIDED CONTACT LENS CASE.
YOU FILL IT
WITH REWETTING SOLUTION
AND AN EXTRA SET
OF CONTACT LENSES,
AND IT CLIPS RIGHT ON
TO YOUR BACKPACK OR KEYCHAIN.
MY PRODUCTS ARE WHAT YOU NEED
WHEN YOU NEED IT.
AND WITH YOUR INVESTMENT TODAY
AND YOUR EXPERTISE,
WE CAN TAKE THIS
TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
WHAT DOES
THE CONTACT LENS STUFF
HAVE TO DO WITH THE GUM?
WELL, THEY'RE
TWO SEPARATE PRODUCTS,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
THEY'RE CLIP'n'GO.
THEY'RE FOR PEOPLE ON THE GO.
ARE YOU REALLY IN
THE CONTAINER BUSINESS
OR THE MINT BUSINESS
OR THE GUM BUSINESS
OR ALL OF THE ABOVE?
(Robert)
OR THE CONTACT BUSINESS?
ALL OF THE ABOVE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
OF ALL THIS STUFF?
WE HAD $817,000 OF SALE‐‐
OF‐‐OF CASH LAST YEAR
IN SALES.
OH, WHOA.
WE HAVE NOT INTRODUCED
THE LENZ YET AT ALL.
WE WERE IN WALGREENS
AND WE WERE IN WINN‐DIXIE.
AND‐‐AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ON AMAZON AND‐‐
THE WORDS "WERE" AND "$800,000"
DON'T REALLY
GO TOGETHER THAT WELL.
WELL,
WE RAN OUT OF PRODUCT.
HOW'S THAT POSSIBLE?
YOU GOT A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS,
YOU GOT $800,000 IN SALES,
AND YOU RUN OUT OF PRODUCT?
IF YOU WORKED FOR ME,
I'D FIRE YOU RIGHT NOW.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT G‐‐
ABOUT GOING AGAINST
THE BIG BRANDS
IS THAT GETTING SHELF SPACE,
GETTING ON THERE‐‐
IT'S VERY HARD
TO STAY ON THERE.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE ON $817,000?
WELL, WE HAVEN'T MADE
REAL PROFIT YET.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WELL, WE PUT IT BACK
INTO THE BUSINESS.
(Robert)
YOU SAY YOU DON'T HAVE‐‐
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE COME OUT ONTO THIS CARPET
THAT NEVER HAD ANYTHING NEAR
WHAT YOU HAD IN SALES?
$800,000,
AND IT JUST VAPORIZED?
OVERHEAD WAS RIDICULOUS.
WELL, THAT'S YOUR FAULT.
I STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT WENT WRONG.
YOU SAY YOU DIDN'T HAVE SALES
'CAUSE YOU DIDN'T HAVE ORDER.
IS IT BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
FINANCE THE ORDERS
OR IS IT BECAUSE
PEOPLE JUST STOPPED BUYING?
WELL, SOME OF THE‐‐
SOME OF THE PLACES
THAT WE HAD THEM IN,
SOME OF THE STORES, WERE DOING
IT FOR PROMOTIONAL PERIODS.
IT WOULD RUN‐‐
BUT WHY DIDN'T THEY REORDER?
THEY CHANGE ALL THE TIME.
I MEAN, ESPECIALLY
IN THE CONFECTION
AND THE MINT AND GUM‐‐
NOT THE MAINSTREAM BRANDS. YOU
CAN STILL FIND THE SAME GUM‐‐
OF COURSE YOU CAN.
BOB, THAT'S HARD, BUT YOU'RE NOT
DOING A GOOD JOB OF EXPLAINING,
'CAUSE SOMEWHERE,
YOU'RE LOSING ME.
(O'Leary) LET ME TRANSLATE,
'CAUSE I THINK I GOT IT.
YOU HAVE A NOVELTY ITEM
THAT SELLS A COMMODITY‐‐
MINTS AND GUMS.
RETAILERS BROUGHT IT IN
BY THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
THEY LOOK
AT THE MARGIN THEY MAKE
AND HOW MUCH SHELF SPACE
YOUR PRODUCT TAKES UP,
DIDN'T MEET THE HURDLE.
THEY REPLACED YOUR STUFF
WITH OTHER STUFF THAT DOES.
IF YOU CAN'T BEAT RUBBER BOOTS,
FOR EXAMPLE,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA STAY IN.
THEY WANT TO PUT
RUBBER BOOTS THERE INSTEAD.
YOU HAD A SUGAR SPIKE.
YOU WENT UP TO $800,000
AND STRAIGHT BACK DOWN
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
STAY ON THE SHELF.
TRUE OR FALSE?
UM, WELL, THEY OR‐‐
THEY REORDERED AND REORDERED.
AND THEN THEY...
STOPPED BECAUSE IT DIDN'T MEET
THE GROSS MARGIN
PER LINEAR INCH.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS. RIGHT?
IS THAT CORRECT? YES‐‐JUST‐‐
IS THAT CORRECT, YES OR NO?
YES. YES.
OKAY, ROB, ROB.
MM‐HMM.
I'M OUT.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE
ON $817,000?
OUR MARGIN'S
ARE ABOUT 32%.
SO ON $800,000 IN SALES,
YOU MADE ABOUT $240,000?
RIGHT.
AND THEN YOU PAID
YOUR EXPENSES, YOURSELF.
WHAT WAS LEFT
AT THE END OF THE DAY?
WELL‐‐WELL, I HAD A, UH,
AN OPERATIONS MANAGER
AND A PRESIDENT
WHO WAS REALLY DOING
A LOT OF THE RUNNING
OF THE DAY‐TO‐DAY BUSINESS.
DID YOU HAVE A LOT OF MONEY
YOU HAD TO THROW AT THIS,
AND HOW MUCH DID YOU PUT IN?
COUPLE MILLION.
(Robert) SORRY. YOU PUT WHAT?
A COUPLE MILLION.
OF YOUR MONEY?
YEAH.
WHERE'D YOU GET THAT MONEY FROM?
WHAT DO YOU DO FOR A LIVING?
I DID WHAT YOU DID.
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPER.
GO BACK TO IT.
SO, BOB, SERIOUSLY,
$2 MILLION?
YEAH.
AND HOW MUCH OF IT
DO YOU HAVE LEFT?
MOST OF IT
WAS OVERHEAD.
AS I SAID, WE MADE MISTAKES.
I MEAN, I GOTTA BE HONEST.
THERE WERE MISTAKES.
OUR OVERHEAD WAS RIDICULOUS.
HOW MUCH WERE YOU PAYING
THESE OTHER GUYS IN OVERHEAD?
$60,000 A MONTH.
OH.
YEAH.
(Daymond) THIS IS GETTING
WORSE AND WORSE.
I'M COMING TO WORK FOR YOU.
I WANT A JOB WITH YOU.
BOB, HONEY, SWEETIE,
POOPSIE BABY,
ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR MIND?
HOW MUCH DID YOU GET
OUT OF THAT?
WERE YOU ON A BIG SALARY,
ROLLING IN THE DOUGH?
NO, I DIDN'T GET ANYTHING.
EVERY QUESTION,
IT GETS WORSE AND WORSE.
HOW MUCH IS LEFT, BOB?
THERE ISN'T.
IT'S GONE?
YEAH.
(groans)
SO ARE YOU STILL FUNDING IT?
ARE YOU PUTTING MORE IN?
NO, I HAVEN'T
FUNDED IT AT ALL.
HE'S COME HERE TO FUND IT
WITH YOUR MONEY.
(laughs)
BOB, BA‐BASICALLY
WHAT I'VE LEARNED,
THANKS TO BARBARA'S QUESTION,
IS YOU TOOK $2 MILLION,
HIRED SOME EXPENSIVE GUYS
THAT GOT YOU
$800,000 IN SALES.
THE SALES WENT AWAY.
YOU FIRED THOSE GUYS.
$2 MILLION'S GONE.
YOU'RE DOWN TO ZERO.
AND YOU'VE INVENTED
TWO NEW PRODUCT LINES,
AND YOU WANT
TO START OVER AGAIN.
ABSOLUTELY.
I'M OUT AGAIN.
(sharks laugh)
BOB, IT'S NOT AN INVESTMENT
THAT‐‐THAT I WOULD MAKE.
I'M OUT ALSO.
♪♪♪
BOB, YOU'RE ALL OVER THE MAP,
MULTIPLE, UH,
PRODUCT LINES
THAT AREN'T RELATED.
THE ONE PRODUCT THAT WAS
SUCCESSFUL IS NOW AT ZERO.
THEN YOU INVENTED OTHER STUFF.
I MEAN, I'M TRYING TO
CHEW ON IT FROM EVERY ANGLE,
AND IT‐‐
AND I STILL GET TO ZERO.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
(O'Leary) BOB, I CAN'T DO IT.
IT JUST MAKES NO SENSE.
GO BACK TO REAL ESTATE.
I'M OUT.
I THINK YOU HAD
A MIXED‐UP PRESENTATION.
BUT I THINK
YOU'RE A DECENT SALESMAN.
THERE'S AN OFFER COMING?
NO, THERE'S NO OFFER COMING.
I AM DEFINITELY OUT.
I JUST WISH I HAD
SOMETHING NICE TO SAY TO YOU...
BARB, I‐I BEG YOU,
PLEASE GIVE‐‐
BEFORE I SAY I'M OUT.
PLEASE GIVE HIM $500,000.
NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
OKAY. GREAT, THANK YOU.
(Daymond) ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, BOB.
(Barbara) THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
BOY, HE DID A BAD JOB
OF HOPPING AROUND ON THAT.
'CAUSE HE HAD TO HIDE THINGS.
I THINK WE GOT TO THE BOTTOM
PRETTY QUICKLY.
OH, WE GAVE HIM SURGERY.
WE GOT RIGHT TO IT.
AMAZING STORY.
I'D LIKE TO SAY TO THE SHARKS,
THANK YOU FOR HELPING ME
SEE SOMETHING THAT
I REALLY NEEDED TO SEE,
AND, UM...
POTENTIALLY SAVE ME
SOME MORE LOSSES.
♪♪♪
I'M APRIL MORRIS.
I'M FROM FISHERS, INDIANA.
AND I'VE CREATED A PRODUCT
THAT HELPS WOMEN
LOOK AND FEEL FABULOUS.
MY COMPANY IS MORE THAN
JUST A BUSINESS TO ME.
IT'S A MESSAGE OF HOPE
THAT ANY DREAM IS POSSIBLE.
AT 17 YEARS OLD, MY PLANS
FOR THE FUTURE ABRUPTLY ENDED
BECAUSE I FOUND OUT THAT
I WAS PREGNANT WITH MY SON.
I GOT MARRIED, 13 MONTHS LATER
I HAD MY DAUGHTER.
AND THEN
I FOUND MYSELF DIVORCED.
I BECAME A SINGLE MOM WITH
TWO KIDS TO RAISE ON MY OWN.
AND I THOUGHT,
I REFUSE TO LIVE
A LIFE OF MEDIOCRITY,
AND I REFUSE
TO BE ANOTHER STATISTIC
OF LIVING OF WELFARE,
AND I'M JUST
GONNA FIGURE IT OUT.
AND THEN ONE DAY,
I STUMBLED UPON THIS IDEA
THAT JUST CAME OUT OF THE BLUE.
BUT I DIDN'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO START IT.
SO THEN I THOUGHT,
WHAT ABOUT REAL ESTATE?
IT TURNS OUT
I WAS REALLY SUCCESSFUL,
AND I SOLD OVER $9 MILLION
IN REAL ESTATE IN ONE YEAR.
I WAS SO GRATEFUL.
AND I FINALLY HAD ENOUGH MONEY.
SO I QUIT SELLING HOMES,
AND THAT'S WHEN I LAUNCHED
MY BUSINESS.
EXPRESS EFFECTS COSMETICS.
THIS IS APRIL.
I'VE INVESTED
EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE.
AND I'M JUST
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY.
AND I NEED THE SHARKS' HELP
TO GET ME TO WHERE I NEED TO BE
SO THAT I CAN CONTINUE
TO LIVE MY DREAM.
AND I'M NOT GIVING UP.
♪♪♪
HELLO. MY NAME IS APRIL MORRIS.
I'M THE CREATOR OF THINgloss.
I'M SEEKING
AN $80,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 20%
EQUITY STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO,
I ATTENDED A CHRISTMAS PARTY
AND I DISCOVERED THAT TWO LADIES
AT THE PARTY THAT I HAD MET
REFERRED TO ME AS CHUBBY.
SO I BEGAN
TO TAKE DIET PILLS.
THEY SEEMED TO WORK,
BUT THE SIDE EFFECTS
WERE MAKING ME JITTERY,
AND I‐I JUST COULDN'T
FALL ASLEEP AT NIGHT,
SO I STOPPED TAKING THEM.
SOMETIME LATER,
I WAS DRIVING IN MY CAR,
AND I BEGAN TO REAPPLY MY
LIP GLOSS IN THE REARVIEW MIRROR
SITTING AT A RED LIGHT
WAITING ON THE LIGHT TO CHANGE,
AND THAT'S
WHEN THE IDEA CAME TO ME.
I THOUGHT, OH MY GOSH.
I WONDER IF THERE'S A SMELL
OR AN HERB OR SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN PUT IN A LIP GLOSS
THAT MAY HELP
TO CURB MY APPETITE
OR AT LEAST
MAKE ME FEEL BETTER.
SO I BEGAN TO DO
A TON OF RESEARCH.
AND I DISCOVERED HOODIA.
HOODIA IS AN HERB FROM
SOUTH AFRICA THAT HAS BEEN KNOWN
TO FOOL YOUR BRAIN
INTO BELIEVING YOUR FULL.
I FOUND OTHER STUDIES
ON OTHER AROMAS.
WHEN INHALED,
THEY HELP TO ENHANCE ENERGY
AND BOOST YOUR MOOD.
SO I STARTED THE DEVELOPMENT
BY COMBINING
ALL OF THESE INGREDIENTS
INTO ONE PRODUCT,
WHICH IS THINgloss.
THINgloss HAS THREE STEPS.
STEP ONE, YOU ACTUALLY
INHALE THE AROMA
THROUGH THE NOSE
30 MINUTES BEFORE YOU EAT.
STEP TWO, IT AC‐‐
YOU ACTUALLY APPLY IT
LIBERALLY ALL OVER THE LIPS,
LIKE SO.
AND STEP THREE, SMILE
AND ENJOY THE BENEFITS.
APRIL, WHAT ARE
YOUR SALES TODAY?
$26,000 AT THE END
OF LAST YEAR.
WHAT ARE YOU ON TRACK FOR
FOR THIS YEAR?
ACTUALLY, MY PERSONAL GOAL IS
TO DO $1 MILLION IN GROSS SALES
BY JULY 1, 2010.
(Barbara) AND HOW MUCH
IS IT SO FAR‐‐
OKAY, BUT JUST SO FAR
THIS YEAR?
$18,000.
WOW.
YOU MAY NOT GET TO LAST YEAR'S
SALES AT THIS RATE.
WITH SOME NEW THINGS COMING UP
AND IN THE WORKS,
I'M FOR CERTAIN
THAT IT'S GONNA GET THERE.
SO, APRIL, DO YOU HAVE
ANY KIND OF CLINICAL STUDIES
ON THE PRODUCT
THAT WILL ALLOW YOU
TO MAKE THOSE CLAIMS?
I HAVE SPOKEN TO
AN F. D. A. ATTORNEY
TO INSURE THAT
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
IN TALKING ABOUT THINgloss
AS A COSMETIC‐‐
THAT IT ACTUALLY ENHANCES
THE APPEARANCE OF WOMEN‐‐
AND SO THAT'S
WHAT I RECOMMEND
IS FOR WOMEN TO TRY IT
FOR THEMSELVES
TO SEE HOW IT WORKS FOR THEM.
BUT SEE, YOU'RE NOT‐‐YOU'RE
NOT SAYING IT'S A COSMETIC.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT IT WILL
HELP YOU LOSE WEIGHT.
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE‐‐
IS SHE ALLOWED
TO DO THAT, KEVIN?
NO, NOT WITHOUT
A CLINICAL STUDY.
APRIL, CAN I‐‐CAN I TRY IT?
ABSOLUTELY.
(Barbara)
SO WHAT'S THE THINKING
THAT YOU SMELL IT
30 MINUTES BEFORE YOU EAT?
WELL, WHAT I DISCOVERED,
UH, IS THAT INHALING
CERTAIN AROMAS THROUGH THE NOSE
CAN INSTANTLY, UM, HELP TO
ENHANCE YOUR MOOD,
MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER
AND ENHANCE ENERGY.
MM‐HMM.
WOW. IT SMELLS GREAT.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK YOU CAN
GO TO $1 MILLION IMMEDIATELY?
WELL, I ACTUALLY HAVE
A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE LARGEST
COSMETIC DISTRIBUTORS
FOR THE COUNTRY OF INDIA.
WHY‐‐WHY DO YOU THINK IND‐‐
INDIA IS SLATED TO HAVE
THE HIGHEST PERCENT OF INCREASE
IN COSMETIC PRODUCTS.
ARE YOU GOING TO INDIA 'CAUSE
YOU CAN GET AROUND THIS ISSUE
THAT KEVIN HARRINGTON
IDENTIFIED‐‐
YOU'RE MAKING A WEIGHT LOSS
CLAIM WITHOUT A CLINICAL STUDY?
I'VE‐‐LIKE I SAID, I'VE SPOKEN
TO AN F. D. A. ATTORNEY.
AND I'M ON TRACK TO KEEP WITHIN
THE GUIDELINES OF THE F. D. A.
LET'S DEAL
WITH THE FACTS.
YOU CAN'T PUT THIS
INTO A LARGE BOX STORE
AND PUT A SIGN UP AND SAY,
"LOSE WEIGHT."
NO, THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I WON'T SAY.
BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS,
I INVITE MY CUSTOMERS
TO TRY THE PRODUCT
FOR THEMSELVES.
IT'S A COSMETIC, AND IT'S MADE
TO ENHANCE THEIR APPEARANCE
AND MAKE THEM FEEL BETTER.
BUT YOU'RE SAYING IT
RIGHT HERE.
IT SAYS "30‐DAY
WEIGHT LOSS CHALLENGE."
SHE'S NOT SAYING THAT.
WHAT'S SHE SAYING?
ROBERT, WHEN YOU SHOW
BEFORE AND AFTERS LIKE THAT,
THAT'S MORE THAN IMPLIED.
IT'S WEIGHT LOSS.
THAT'S THE SAME AS‐‐
IS THE LAW CLEAR ON THAT?
OH, YEAH.
HAVE YOU BEEN TO INDIA, APRIL?
I HAVE NOT.
I'VE BEEN TO INDIA.
AND, UH, I'LL TELL YOU THIS‐‐
IT'S ONE OF THE POOREST
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD.
IT WOULD BE
BEYOND SHOCKING TO ME
THAT A LIP GLOSS
THAT HELPS PEOPLE LOSE WEIGHT
WOULD BE A HUGE SELLER THERE.
I'D BE VERY CAREFUL
WITH A DISTRIBUTOR
THAT'S TELLING YOU HE'S GONNA
GET YOU TO $1 MILLION IN SALES.
WELL, THERE'S ALSO
HUGE IMPORT DUTIES
BRINGING PRODUCTS
INTO INDIA.
I'M NOT RELYING
ON INDIA TOTALLY
BECAUSE I HAVE
JUST SIGNED AGREEMENTS
WITH OTHER DISTRIBUTORS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
UM, SO I'VE GOT MANY OTHER
THINGS IN THE WORKS AS WELL.
HERE'S THE THING
WITH DISTRIBUTORS‐‐
EVERYBODY IS A DISTRIBUTOR
IF THEY'LL TAKE YOUR MONEY
AND TAKE YOUR PRODUCT.
NOW ARE ANY OF THESE
DISTRIBUTORS OFFERING YOU MONEY
AHEAD OF TIME ON SIGNING?
NO, THEY'RE NOT.
IF YOU GET BIG, AND I WAS
TO ACTUALLY GIVE YOU $80,000,
AND WE AGITATED THE GOVERNMENT
THAT STOPS THIS KIND OF CLAIM,
IT COULD BE BAD FOR BOTH OF US.
THEY CAN BE VERY NASTY
WHEN THEY GET PISSED OFF.
ISN'T THAT SOMETHING
THAT'S ON YOUR MIND?
OF COURSE IT'S ON MY MIND.
MY INTENTION IS TO WORK
WITH THE F. D. A.
AND INSURE THAT I STAY
WITHIN THE GUIDELINES,
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE.
HOW MUCH IS IT, APRIL?
THINgloss SELLS FOR $28.
WOW. WOW.
(Robert) $28 FOR THIS?
(April) YES.
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE.
HOW MUCH IS NORMAL LIP GLOSS
FOR A WOMAN?
$8.
YOU CAN GET AN $8 LIP GLOSS
PROBABLY AT A DRUG STORE.
BUT WHEN YOU GO
INTO A DEPARTMENT STORE,
YOU CAN FIND LIP GLOSSES
ANYWHERE FROM $18 UP TO $40.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU
PER CAPSULE OR TUBE?
BETWEEN $4 AND $5.
BIG MARKUP.
WOW.
(O'Leary) THOSE ARE
FANTASTIC MARGINS.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU'VE
LOST WEIGHT WITH THIS PRODUCT.
I HAVE. I'VE LOST
ALMOST 18 POUNDS SINCE I GOT
THE VERY FIRST SAMPLE
ALMOST TWO YEARS AGO.
APRIL, I WOULD BE VERY NERVOUS
ABOUT GETTING INVOLVED WITH IT
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY LEGAL, UH,
CATEGORY‐‐WEIGHT LOSS.
AND I'M GONNA‐‐
I'M OUT ON THIS ONE.
YEAH, YOU KNOW,
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE F. D. A. THING WITH IT,
SO I'M OUT.
I THINK I KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'VE DONE HERE.
AND, UM...
I COMMEND IT,
BUT I CAN'T ENDORSE IT.
THIS CLAIM
GOES OVER THE EDGE.
KEVIN HARRINGTON FREAKED ME OUT
WITH HIS CONCERNS ABOUT THIS.
THAT'S WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
♪♪♪
I THINK I'M UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE, UH,
SALES PITCH ON IT,
THAT IT'S AN IMPLIED BENEFIT
THAT CAN'T HAVE CLARITY.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH YOUR...
UH, GRAY AREA OF CLAIM.
I THINK YOU CAN FIX THAT.
MY ONLY ISSUE WITH IT
IS YOUR CLAIM
TO GO FROM $35,000 TO $1 MILLION
IN SALES IN 12 MONTHS.
I HAVE BUILT
A LOT OF BUSINESSES
AND HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYONE
GROW AT THAT RATE.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION.
AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING WHAT HAPPENS
A YEAR FROM NOW.
I LOVE THE CONFIDENCE.
♪♪♪
I THINK IT'S VERY SCARY
TO GO ON THE FRINGE CLAIM
ASPECT OF THIS.
SHE'S UNDER THE RADAR
RIGHT NOW.
(Barbara) OH, YES, YES, YES.
ONCE SHE COMES ABOVE
THE RADAR, BOOM.
THE FOOT COMES DOWN AND...
BIG TROUBLE.
I'M NOT DISCOURAGED AT ALL.
THE PURPOSE OF ME
EVEN HAVING THINgloss
IS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
WOMEN DESERVE
TO LOOK AND FEEL BEAUTIFUL.
AND I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO DO THAT,
AND I WILL MAKE MY GOAL.
♪♪♪
NEXT UP ARE GEORGE PODD
AND ROLF SCHWARTZ,
WHO HOPE TO BRING NEW LIFE
TO A CONVENTIONAL PRODUCT.
HELLO, EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS GEORGE PODD.
THIS IS ROLF SCHWARTZ.
AND WE REPRESENT
LIGHTFILM LLC.
TODAY WE'RE CURRENTLY SEEKING
$100,000
FOR A 5% OWNERSHIP STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
OUR PRODUCT IS A LIGHT‐UP DECAL
FOR CAR WINDOWS.
RIGHT HERE IS MY CAR
WITH THE AMERICAN WAVING FLAG.
I HAVE PEOPLE PULL ME OVER
SAYING, "WHAT IS THAT?
I HAVE NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE."
THIS WAVES WITH A MOTION SENSOR
AND A LIGHT SENSOR.
IT KNOWS WHEN TO GO ON
BY ITSELF.
WE KNOW WE HAVE A WINNER
WITH THIS ITEM.
WE'VE MARKET TESTED IT
AT THE TRADE‐SHOW LEVEL.
IT'S A SIMPLE APPLICATION.
IT'S A PEEL AND STICK.
YOU PEEL IT,
AND THEN YOU STICK IT
ON YOUR WINDOW
JUST LIKE THIS.
IT'S A FLUSH MOUNTED.
NO TOOLS REQUIRED.
ONCE IT'S IN, YOU'RE DONE.
IS THERE A WIRE
ATTACHED TO THAT?
THERE'S A WIRE ATTACHED
IN THIS ONE.
THIS IS
GENERATION ONE PRODUCT.
WE'RE INTO
OUR GENERATION TWO PRODUCT,
WHICH WE'RE MOVING INTO
A CORDLESS APPLICATION.
RIGHT NOW.
(O'Leary) HOW DOES IT GET
POWERED IF IT'S CORDLESS?
UH, THROUGH A BATTERY PACK,
AND THEN ALSO WE'VE GOT
THE SOLAR CHARGE CHARGING
THE BATTERY DURING THE DAY.
SO DURING THE DAY,
IT'S A REGULAR DECAL.
AND THEN AT NIGHTTIME,
IT LIGHTS UP AND ANIMATES.
DO YOU OWN A PATENT?
YES.
WELL, ACTUALLY, WE HAVE
A PATENT APPLICATION.
SO IT'S CURRENTLY FILED.
GEORGE, IS THIS A SAFETY DEVICE
OR IS IT A‐‐
WELL, THE KEY MARKET IS
FOR THE BRAND AFFINITY‐‐
THE GUY
THAT GOES TO A COLLEGE
AND HE WANTS THAT LOGO
ON HIS VEHICLE, PRO SPORTS‐‐
IF THERE WAS A KID
IN COLLEGE
AND WANTED
HIS PARTICULAR SPORTS TEAM,
HE ORDERS
THAT SPECIFIC DECAL FROM YOU?
HE COULD DOWN THE ROAD.
NO QUESTION.
YES.
WELL, I THINK
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE HERE.
RIGHT.
YOU'RE HERE TO HELP GET MONEY
FOR DISTRIBUTION,
I'M GOING TO ASSUME.
EXACTLY. WE'LL USE THE $100,000
TO GO AFTER THESE NICHE SECTORS
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE, YOU KNOW,
SOME VERBAL COMMITMENTS
SO THAT WE CAN IN TURN
GO TO A MAJOR RETAILER
WITH CONFIDENCE
AND‐‐AND SOME TRACK RECORD.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THE IDEA? I'D BE SO CURIOUS.
IT'S A GREAT STORY.
UM, MY SON PLAYS HOCKEY.
I WAS DROPPING HIM OFF
AT THE HOCKEY RINK,
AND THE VEHICLE IN FRONT OF ME
HAD THE TEAM LOGO
OF THE HOCKEY TEAM.
AT THE SAME, A CHILD IN THAT
VEHICLE WAS WATCHING CARTOONS
THROUGH THE FLIP‐DOWN
DVD MONITOR.
AND I WAS WATCHING HIS CARTOON
RIGHT THROUGH
THE BACK OF THE WINDOW.
AND I'M LIKE, "WAIT A MINUTE.
YOU‐‐YOU GOT A LOGO
AND YOU GOT CARTOONS
AND ANIMATION.
WHAT IF THE TWO TECHNOLOGIES
MERGED TOGETHER?
IT WOULD BRING STICKERS
AND BRANDING
TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
WHERE DID YOU GO FIND IT?
WELL, MY BACKGROUND
IS INDUSTRIAL DESIGN.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN WORKING
ON NEW PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT.
THE FIRST PROJECT I WORKED ON
OUT OF COLLEGE
WAS, UH, THE FIRST
HOME PREGNANCY TEST.
I DID THE WHOLE LINE
OF SEARS WET/DRY VACUUM CLEANERS
FOR THE CRAFTSMAN BRAND.
MY BACKGROUND IS FINANCIAL.
I'VE KNOWN GEORGE FOR YEARS,
AND HE TOLD ME ABOUT IT.
I HAD THE VISION RIGHT AWAY.
SO YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL.
ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES TODAY?
THEY'RE‐‐WE‐‐WE‐‐ZERO.
WE'RE WAITING TO GET MONEY
RIGHT NOW.
GEORGE, IF YOU BELIEVE
IN THE PRODUCT,
WHY NOT TAKE SOME OF
YOUR OWN MONEY AND SELL‐‐
I'VE PUT ALL MY MONEY
INTO THIS.
HOW MUCH YOU PUT IN?
UM...
ABOUT $750,000.
PARDON ME?
WHOA.
$750,000?
WOW.
AND IT WENT INTO PURE R&D
TO DEVELOP IT?
R&D.
PATENTS.
HIRED A COUPLE OF LAW FIRMS
TO DO ALL THE DUE DILIGENCE.
THE FIRST THING I CHECKED
WAS THE LEGALITY OF IT...
MM‐HMM.
THE STREET LEGAL ASPECT
OF IT.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO PRODUCE ONE LOGO?
AND WHAT COULD YOU
SELL IT FOR?
THIS UNIT HERE,
AROUND $10.
BUT OUR
NEXT GENERATION PRODUCT,
WHICH IS
THE SOLAR BATTERY UNIT,
WE CAN‐‐WE COULD EASILY
MAKE THAT FOR $5 OR LESS
BASED ON VOLUME.
YOU CAN MAKE IT FOR $5
AND YOU SELL IT AT W‐‐
WELL, THE WHOLESALE
WOULD BE $10,
AND THEN THE RETAIL WOULD BE
$19.99 OR, YOU KNOW,
DEPENDING ON WHAT LICENSING
DEAL YOU HAD, TOO, AS WELL.
DO YOU HAVE THOSE
LICENSING DEALS IN PLACE?
WE‐‐WE DON'T
HAVE THEM IN PLACE.
WE HAVE THE GREEN LIGHT
TO TAKE 'EM TO THE NEXT LEVEL
WITH HARLEY‐DAVIDSON.
HARLEY‐‐
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
THOSE DEALS WILL COST YOU?
DAYMOND, DO YOU HAVE TO
PAY THEM?
OF COURSE YOU DO.
YOU GOTTA PAY 'EM
A DOWN PAYMENT FEE,
AND THEN A‐‐AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
PROMISE TO MAKE X‐AMOUNT‐‐
GIVE THEM X‐AMOUNT OF DOLLARS
OVER THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
(George) EXACTLY.
(Robert) WOW.
THIS IS WHERE I MADE ALL MY
MONEY, LICENSING OUT MY BRANDS.
SO WE HAVE A GREAT TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S VERY INTERESTING
FOR DISPLAY SIGNS.
THAT'S STAGE ONE
OF THIS BUSINESS.
MM‐HMM.
NOW WE HAVE TO HAVE
A MARKETING PLAN
AND A SALES PLAN
AND A DISTRIBUTION PLAN...
CORRECT.
TO CAPITALIZE ON IT.
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE AT.
CORRECT. RIGHT.
WHY IS $100,000 ENOUGH?
YOU NEED MORE MONEY THAN THAT.
WELL, I THINK I CAN GET
THAT FOUNDATION LEVEL DONE
IN THOSE NICHE SECTORS
THAT THE MONEY WILL GENERATE
BACK ON ITSELF
TO FUND TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
(Robert)
SO ANSWER THIS FOR ME.
HOW DOES IT BECOME
REALLY BIG?
WELL, THAT'S THE NEXT LEVEL
OF FUNDING, OBVIOUSLY.
TO GET IT REALLY BIG, YOU'RE
GONNA NEED A LOT OF CASH,
'CAUSE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO PAY
FOR ALL THESE LICENSES.
MM‐HMM. MM‐HMM.
RIGHT.
(Harrington) GUYS, I'VE‐‐
I'VE MADE MY MIND UP.
I REALLY LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE,
BUT I'M CONCERNED THE $100,000
THAT I WOULD PUT UP
WOULD GO INTO A BLACK HOLE
BECAUSE YOU NEED REALLY
ANOTHER $1 MILLION IMMEDIATELY
TO REALLY TAKE THIS THING
AND DEVELOP IT.
SO I'M GONNA MAKE IT EASY FOR
THE REST OF YOU GUYS. I'M OUT.
THE THING IS,
THIS PRODUCT SCREAMS
FOR A STRATEGIC PARTNER
THAT HAS DISTRIBUTION.
YEP.
YOU KNOW, IT'S INTRIGUING.
IT REALLY IS.
BUT I'M ONLY
HALF THE SOLUTION.
THIS IS ONE OF THESE
RARE SITUATIONS
WHERE CASH IS NOT ENOUGH.
I COULD GIVE YOU $1 MILLION,
AND IT STILL WOULDN'T SOLVE
THE PROBLEM WE ALL
SIT HERE FACING‐‐DISTRIBUTION.
FOR THAT REASON, GUYS,
I'M OUT.
♪♪♪
GEORGE, I‐I REALLY...
I REALLY LIKE THE PRODUCT.
I THINK YOU GUYS
DID A GREAT JOB.
BUT AS THE FELLOW SHARK
ILLUSTRATED,
NO AMOUNT OF MONEY
IS GONNA HELP YOU
BRING IT TO MARKET
WITHOUT THE RIGHT PARTNER.
I‐I'M OUT.
I'M NOT ONLY THE WRONG PARTNER,
I'M THE WRONG CUSTOMER.
IF MY HUSBAND PUT THAT
ON MY CAR, I'D KILL HIM.
(Robert laughs)
YOU MEAN YOUR ROLLS ROYCE
WOULDN'T LOOK GOOD WITH THAT?
SO I'M OUT.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
AND DAYMOND IS
GEORGE AND ROLF'S LAST CHANCE
TO GET A DEAL.
(Daymond)
HERE'S MY PROBLEM‐‐
I WOULD NEED TO ONLY BE IN
IF THE SECOND PHASE WORKS.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN THE ONE
WITH THE WIRES.
I CAN ACTUALLY
ISSUE YOU SOME LICENSES.
RIGHT.
FORGET EVEN MY FUBU BUSINESS.
IF I GIVE YOU COOGI, ONE OF
MY OTHER LINES, WHICH IS...
OH, COOGI, YEAH.
THE NUMBER ONE URBAN LINE
IN THE COUNTRY,
ALONE YOU'RE GONNA MAKE
$1 MILLION OFF THAT...
MM‐HMM.
AS A LICENSE.
YOU GO OUT TO A STORE, AND YOU
GET $2 MILLION IN ORDERS,
YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IT.
I MANUFACTURE IT,
I SHIP IT, I‐‐
OH, YOU DO
THE MANUFACTURING, TOO?
EVERYTHING, YES.
OOH.
BUT I WOULD ONLY BE IN
IF THE SECOND PHASE WORKS.
I'M NOT INTERESTED
IN THE ONE WITH THE WIRES.
AND I WOULD NEED
75% OF THE COMPANY.
♪♪♪
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND IS OFFERING
THE MONEY THEY'RE SEEKING,
BUT HE WANTS A HUGE STAKE
IN THEIR COMPANY.
SO FOR 75% OF THE COMPANY
I WILL GIVE YOU $100,000.
I WILL GIVE YOU
UNLIMITED FINANCING
ON YOUR ORDERS.
I JUST HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PATENT IS CLEAR
AND THAT IT WOULD BE
FOR THE SECOND STAGE PRODUCT
THAT I KNOW WOULD WORK.
I WOULD ALSO OFFER YOU
THE BRANDS THAT I OWN
AS LICENSES.
NO MONEY DOWN, NO MINIMUMS.
YOU WOULD GET THOSE IMMEDIATELY.
AND THAT IS MY OFFER.
DAYMOND, ARE YOU SAYING
YOU'RE OFFERING
$100,000 FOR 75%
OF THE PRODUCT?
WITH GUARANTEED MANUFACTURING,
NO NEED TO EVER RAISE
ANY MORE FUNDS.
MM, THAT'S INTERESTING.
(Daymond) THEY WILL NEVER HAVE
TO LOOK FOR ANOTHER INVESTOR.
WOW.
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT.
CAN WE COUNTER?
SURE.
I WOULD‐‐I WOULD LIKE
TO PARTNER WITH YOU.
I CAN SEE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THE WHOLE BUSINESS
THAT WE'RE GOING AFTER.
HOWEVER, WE WOULD LIKE TO RECOUP
OUR ORIGINAL INVESTMENT
OUT OF THE DEAL,
IF POSSIBLE.
AND‐‐AND BE ABLE
TO‐‐TO LIVE.
CAN YOU LIVE WITH 51%?
GEORGE, IS YOUR COUNTER
$100,000?
NO, NO. I DIDN'T GET
TO THE NUMBER YET.
(O'Leary) THAT'S THE POINT.
LET'S HEAR THAT.
WHAT'S THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT?
IT'S ROUGHLY $750,000.
YEAH, BABY.
SO YOUR COUNTER IS $750,000
FOR 51%?
AND HE WOULD R‐RUN
THE COMPANY,
AND THEN WE‐‐OBVIOUSLY
WE'D WORK FOR HIM.
♪♪♪
I'M LOVING THIS.
AND WE WANT TO‐‐AND WE WANT
TO PARTNER WITH YOU.
WHAT IF‐‐IF YOU HAD 51%
OF THE‐‐OF THE EQUITY,
BUT THEY GOT AN ACCELERATED
SHARE OF THE PROFITS?
UNTIL THE $750,000's
PAID OUT.
UNTIL THEY GET BACK
THEIR $750,000.
(Daymond) I LIKE THAT.
YEAH, I LIKE THAT.
WHAT IS THE AMOUNT OF CASH THAT
YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE TODAY
TO SELL 75% OF YOUR BUSINESS?
MM.
ROBERT, WHY ARE YOU TRYING
TO MESS UP DAYMOND'S DEAL?
ROBERT, ARE YOU TRYING TO GET
CLARITY OR YOU WANT TO OFFER‐‐
I SENSED AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BUY A GREAT PRODUCT.
SO YOU‐‐YOU WANT
TO COME IN ON THIS?
I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE DOLLAR AMOUNT IS
TO BUY 75% OF THIS COMPANY.
SEE, I'M KINDA GOING BACK
TO THE 51%.
AND, ROLF, WHAT'S THE NUMBER
FOR 51% OF THE BUSINESS?
I WANT TO KEEP IT
AROUND THE $750,000,
TO RECOUP
OUR‐‐OUR INVESTMENT.
GUYS, CAN YOU STEP OUT
IN THE HALL FOR A SECOND?
SURE.
DAYMOND,
YOU ARE ONE GREEDY SHARK.
GREEDY, GREEDY, SHARK.
YEAH, BUT HE'S TAKING AWAY
ALL OF HIS FUTURE PROBLEMS.
(O'Leary) YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE A VAMPIRE.
YOU'RE SUCKING THE LIFE
OUT OF GEORGE.
(laughs)
EVERY LAST DROP OF BLOOD,
LEAVING HIM 25% FOR HIS ORGANS
TO JUST SCRATCH OUT A LIVING ON.
(laughs)
WOW.
YOU'RE GETTING EXCITED.
DAYMOND, I'M SENSING IN THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE ANSWERING
THAT THEY WOULD SELL 75%
OF THIS BUSINESS FOR $100,000.
NO. NO WAY.
(O'Leary) NO.
THIS IS IT. I THINK THEY HAVE
NOWHERE LEFT TO GO.
WHY DON'T YOU OFFER 'EM
THE $100,000
AND SEE WHERE THEY GO?
THEN HOW DO THEY GET
THEIR $750,000 BACK?
AND 75 CENTS OUT OF EVERY $1
OF PROFIT GOES TO THEM.
UNTIL THEY GET
THEIR MONEY BACK.
(Robert) YEAH.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE.
♪♪♪
OKAY, GUYS.
SO ROBERT IS INTERESTED
IN COMING IN.
I'D LOVE IT.
BUT HERE'S WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
IF ROBERT'S IN, I NEED
TO KIND OF PUT THAT NUMBER
BACK WHERE I WAS,
IN THAT RANGE.
YOU WOULD GET THE $100,000,
YOU WOULD GET
THE UNLIMITED FINANCING.
BUT WE STILL NEED
70% OF THE COMPANY.
UPON SALES, YOU WOULD RECEIVE
75 CENTS ON EVERY $1
UNTIL YOU RECOUP $750,000.
CAN WE GET
A LITTLE MORE CASH UP FRONT?
I MEAN, I WANT TO PARTNER
WITH YOU GUYS.
I WANT TO MAKE A DEAL HAPPEN.
(whispers) CAN WE ADD MAYBE
ANOTHER $100,000
OR IS THAT ASKING TOO MUCH?
MAYBE $200,000?
(whispers) YEAH.
(normal voice) COULD WE, UH,
DO EVERYTHING YOU JUST SAID,
CAN WE GET $200,000 UP FRONT
SO WE CAN BREATHE?
BREATHE.
YOU WANT SOME AIR,
YOU WANT A LITTLE FOOD...
YEAH.
AND THIS VAMPIRE
IS JUST SUCKING YOU DRY?
(laughs)
I THINK YOU GUYS
ARE BREATHING ALREADY.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE HEALTHY.
♪♪♪
DEAL?
GUYS,
YOU GOTTA MAKE A DECISION,
'CAUSE I CAN'T
SIT HERE MUCH LONGER.
I KNOW.
(whispers) BANK IT, RIGHT?
WE ACCEPT THE DEAL.
(normal voice) WE'LL TAKE IT.
I'M THRILLED...
(Daymond) YOU GOT IT?
ABSOLUTELY THRILLED TO BE
PARTNERED WITH YOU GUYS.
GREAT. I'M IN.
GOOD JOB.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL MAKE SOME MONEY, OKAY?
WE'LL TAKE YOUR PROBLEMS
OFF YOUR HANDS.
THANKS, GUYS.
(Rolf) THANK YOU.
(Daymond) WE'RE GONNA
MAKE MONEY, ALL RIGHT?
(O'Leary) CONGRATULATIONS.
I JUST SENSED
THIS WAS THE LAST STOP.
YOU WERE ON THEM
LIKE A BUZZARD ON A GUT WAGON
AS SOON AS YOU SAW
THE WAY HE LOOKED.
(laughs) THAT'S ROBERT. YOU JUST
DESCRIBED HIM. HE'S ENTRAILS.
THAT CARCASS HAD ONLY
A LITTLE PIECE OF MEAT ON IT.
I LIKE YOUR STYLE, BABY.
THE VAMPIRE AND THE LEECH.
GIVING UP 70% OF OUR COMPANY,
UH, IS‐‐IS KIND OF SHOCKING,
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN LIVING
AS THE OWNERS OF THIS COMPANY
FOR THREE YEARS.
HOWEVER, WE THOUGHT
IT WAS MOST IMPORTANT THAT
WE GOT WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE
TO MAKE LIGHTFILM
AT THE HIGH LEVEL
WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO.
♪♪♪
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪